3 weeks after his resurrection, he
appears to the disciples again. John
21:15-17. So when they had eaten
breakfast, Jesus said to Simon Peter,
Simon son of Jonah, do you love me more
than these? Meaning the fish, do you
love me more than the fish and your
trade? Because he's a fisherman. They
were out fishing that that morning. What
does Simon say? Yes, Lord.
He said to him, "Yes, Lord, you know
that I love you." He said to him, "Feed
my lambs." He said to him again a second
time, "Simon, son of Jonah, do you love
me?" He said to him, "Yes, Lord, you
know that I love you." He said to him,
"Tend my sheep." He said to him the
third time, "Simon, son of Jonah, do you
love me?" Peter was grieved because he
said to him the third time, "Do you love
me?" And he said to him, "Lord, you know
all things. You know that I love you."
Jesus said to him, "Feed my sheep." In
other words, what Peter's saying, why
are you even bothering asking me? We
already know that you know all things.
You know all hearts. You know what's in
our heart. You know if we love you or
not. So why are you asking? You know all
things. So wait, before his death, he
knows all things. After his death, he
knows all things. So Jesus wasn't asking
because he didn't know. He was asking
for a different reason.
making
sense and every one of you know why he's
asking here is the compassionate
merciful loving heart of Jesus Peter
denied him three times so what did Jesus
do he didn't come to Peter and say shame
on you here I am alive in the flesh what
do you got to say for yourself you deny
me three
times what should I do to you now that's
not Jesus you know Jesus is instead of
Peter saying, "Jesus, son of God, do you
still love me after betraying you?"
Notice the humbleness of our Lord,
Simon, son of Jonah, do you love
me? Notice what the Lord is saying. He's
not he's it's not Peter asking him,
"Lord, do you still love me after I
betrayed you? How could you still love
me? I'm No, no, no, no. That's not the
heart of Christ. It's the
opposite. Jesus loves you to the end and
forever. If Jesus is in love with you
and you are his, he loves you forever.
So he tells Simon, "Simon, do you love
me?" "Yes, Lord, you know I love you.
Feed my sheep." Simon, do you love me?
Yes, Lord, you know I love you. Feed my
lamb. Simon, do you love me? The reason
why he asked him three times is to make
him confess and undo all the times he
denied him. For every time you denied
me, I will lovingly, gently restore
you and use you again. I don't know this
man. Simon, do you love me? Yes, I do. I
swear I don't know this man. Simon, do
you love me? Yes, I do. I'm telling you,
I don't know this man. Simon, do you
love me? Yes, Lord. You know I love you.
He restored him. But then he says
something
else. He says something else.
Now that you say you love me, you're
going to have to show me your love,
Simon. Here's what I expect from you.
Here's what I demand of you. If you love
me, if you love
me, then you're going to love my church,
feed my church, care for my church, and
watch over my church. Because those who
love me will keep my word. Those who
love me, Father, please bless the
connection in Jesus name. Ya, please
Lord, I hate when it buffers, not
connected to the outer motor. Those who
love me will keep my word. Those who
love me will obey my command. So, Simon,
you've now confessed your love. Show me
your love and action. And no better way
of showing me that you love me but by
loving my church, caring for my
church, watching over my church,
teaching my church, and protecting my
church from mobs, snakes, and
scorpions.
Okay, everyone with me? Focus. Don't be
distracted. Do you know why original
designer? I'm sure you've been duped by
preachers who tell you that Jesus says
to Simon, "Do you agape me?" And Simon
says, "Yes, I fileto you." Do you agape
me? Yes, I fleto you. And then the third
time Jesus says, "Do you fto me?" "Yes,
I fleto." See, Peter just fleto Jesus.
Have you heard that stupid
argument? Original. It seems by your
question, you fell for that stupid
argument. Tell me you've heard someone
tell you that and deceive you.
Were you deceived by that
argument? Tell me so I can help
you. Original
designer. Folks, you're going to hear a
silly, stupid teaching that
unfortunately I bought into because I
was an ignoramus. But thank the Lord
that when we seek his face, when we seek
the Holy Spirit, he doesn't leave us
ignorant anymore, but gives us the
desires of our heart. And if we want to
know him, he will make himself known.
and give us wisdom to know him and love
him. Guys, you may not see it in the
English. In the Greek, this is what you
read. John 21:15. Let me get you the
link. Hold on. Okay. It's sad that
people teach these things, but it's
okay. Here.
Here. I fell for it, too, guys. So,
don't don't feel bad. If you go and
look, you don't even need to know the
Greek. Just read the translation. It
says, "Simon, son of John, love you me.
Agapas me.
Then go and read what he
says. It
says no. It's fileto. It's fo from
fileto. Notice Peter didn't say agape.
He said
fo. Peter.
You see
that? See, they'll tell you it's two
different Greek words. Focus, guys. Two
different Greek words. See, Peter
doesn't agape Jesus. He only files
Jesus. Oh, these arguments, man. Okay.
But then the third time, Jesus changes
the word because now Jesus says,
"Simon, do
you flesh me?" file me not agape me from
fileto. You understand the argument?
Jesus went from saying, "Simon, do you
agape me?" And Peter said, "Nah, I just
fleto you." And then Jesus again said,
"Simon, do you agape me?" "Nah, I just
filet owe you." And then the third time
says, "Okay, Simon, do you file me?" And
he got hurt. Yes, Lord. You know I
fileto owe you even though I don't agape
you. Seriously.
No, honestly, that's what the I'm not
exaggerating. I've heard sermons on
this. Let me tell you why that's a
foolish
argument. Just like English, even in
Greek, words can be used synonymously.
Agape and
fileto can depending on the context have
different nuances of meaning but also
can overlap and be used synonymously.
Are you with me there? Okay. Yes, there
are places in which there may be a
slight nuanced meaning to the use of
fileto in contrast agape, but often
times they're used
interchangeably. So that agape will mean
file, fileo will mean agape. You'll find
out in many languages. Okay, here I'll
give you example. I can say to Anna, I
love you. Or I can say I adore you.
And in an Assyrian, if I
say, see, they're different words, but
they are synonymous. It's the context
that will determine if they're
synonymous. But if we're going to play
that game, you know what you end up
proving? You end up proving that in John
5:20, the father doesn't love Jesus. He
merely likes Jesus. Do you know why?
Because in John
5:20, Jesus says, "The father file the
son." John 5:20, "For the father loves
the son." Original designer. Do you know
what the word love there is? When Jesus
says the father loves the son, it's not
agape. It's not agape. It comes from the
word fto. It's right there. He puts the
Greek
Fileto. Now, who would be that dumb to
say, see, the father only likes Jesus a
lot because he fileto the son, but he
doesn't agape
him. Seriously. But can I tell you which
translation does translate it
differently? The New World Translation
in John
5:20. In John 5:20, the New World
Translation actually translates fellow
differently. It says, "The father is
having affection for the son." You see
it? John 5:20, "For the father has
affection for the
son." Did you catch
it? You see how they translated the word
fileo? That's a new translation of
Jehovah's Witnesses. The father has
affection for the son because they too
bought into this stupidity that if it's
filet from fileto then it has a
different shade or nuance of meaning
than
agape. You you got it right? But in John
3:35, in John 17:24, we are told the
father
agape the son and the father has been
agapeing the son from before the world
was created. Who in their right mind
would think just because here it's fo
that means the father doesn't have agape
love for the son and that his love is
not intense and infinite and perfect.
Okay. So anyone who tells you in John
21:15-17 that there Jesus said,"Simon,
do you agape me?" Nah, Lord, I just
fleto you. Oh, okay. Simon, but do you
agape me? Nah, Lord, I just file you.
All right, Simon, I'll settle for file.
Do you file me? Yes, Lord, I fo. All
right, I'll have to settle for
fileo. Really? Does anyone think for a
moment that's the meaning of John
21:15-17? Jesus is settling for less
than
agape. Do you agape me? No, I fo you.
But do you agape me? No, I fo you. All
right, I'll settle for fileo. All right,
Jesus. Now we got a
deal. It's like me saying to someone, a
girl, do you love me? Nah, I just like
you. Come on, sweetie. Do you love me?
No, I like you. All right, but do you
like me enough to go out with me and
have some ice cream? Yeah, I like you
enough. Okay, remember, you can only get
married on this side of
eternity. Okay, we're good. All right.
Right. You understand? It's silly,
right? So, what are you trying to say,
Anna? You fo me, but you don't agape me,
Anna?
All
right. All right. But anyway, did we
answer that
objection? Gee, Diana, you would know,
huh? All right. Everyone else, do you
understand? Don't make a big deal over
the fact that in the Greek the words are
not the same. Understand? Like any
language, you can use two different
words
synonymously. You can say perfect, you
can say complete. You can say love. You
can say adore and it means the same
thing. How do you know when it means the
same thing? Context. How do you know
when it may not be mean the same thing?
Context. I'll give you example of
context here. Do you love me? No, I
don't. I like you, but I don't love you.
See, right there, I can see like doesn't
mean
love. You get my point? Context will
determine what the words mean.
Obviously, Peter's not going to say to
Jesus, "Lord, I don't know if I agape
you. You know, I'm having some doubts
whether I can agape you, but will you
settle for fel? After all, I denied you
three times, and now you've been raised
from the dead, immortal, deathless, and
now I know you're God in the flesh, but
all I can give you is fo." Could you
settle for that?
Yeah. Uh oh. Now definitely if I use
fileo for David
Wood, if I use fileo for David Wood, you
know it ain't agape cuz that man makes
it impossible for anyway anyone to agape
Yeah.